you are a first time Grammy nominee how
does it feel how proud are you I mean it
feels insane and to share it with Sam to
someone who's so special
[Music]
it feels really incredible and I just
feel honored and grateful for everyone
who's like been with me for all these
years all my fans especially it's been
years of you know getting to this point
where that could happen so thanks guys
lots of well-deserved what were those
text messages like with you and Sam on
the morning that you heard about the
nomination oh my God just like crazy
amount of emojis voice memos voice notes
yeah we were just going crazy it was so
exciting
are you gonna bring that excitement to
the stage because you are also
performing at the Grandview what his
life is this is fun it's crazy
um yeah I've been in rehearsals and it's
definitely going to be very explosive
and fun oh are you bringing pyro to the
stage explosive
I gave it away
[Music]
in interviews I just say everything I'm
sorry when we think of a performance
yeah we think of go big or go home yeah
for sure it's definitely go big or go
home okay it's the Grammys it's the
Grammys yeah what about the Wardrobe go
big or go home I'm like yeah well
there's multiple looks you got to think
about it so it's a red carpet in the
beginning the performance sitting down
potential you know when the category
comes on uh so there's a lot of looks
involved there's a lot of look so we've
been in fittings back to back but
they're they're very good wow I'm
excited we know you bring the a game
when it comes to Fashion so I'm so
excited to see what you have in store
but I wanted to ask you I wanted to
bring it back to Sam for a second
because Sam is receiving a lot of hate
right now for their latest music video
being quote unquote too sexual what do
you make of the people who have
something to say about that pop music is
supposed to be that way it's been that
way for forever I Sam is one of the
sweetest people I've personally ever met
and one of the most talented people I've
personally ever met and I just yeah I
just I love it self-expression and I
think it's we're kind of going backwards
a little bit you know by just not
letting everyone Express their sexuality
and I think it's really beautiful to be
able to do that and really strong so uh
yeah people are just so judgmental and I
I hate that and I love Sam to pieces and
uh kindest person to most talented
person
[Music]
thank you